okay so first video update in a while
hello everyone August first that's when
we're coming back with the first live
show you know I've been gone for about a
week and a half now at the lake cottage
and right now I'm just actually I don't
know if you can see the water I go into
town there's a gym there I go maybe like
once or twice a week just to kind of
keep active but you know I gotta say I
really I'm looking forward to getting
back we kind of left right yeah I mean I
haven't taken a break like this in a
long time and I want to get to that in a
second I think it's important for
everyone to do but right before we kind
of took this this break which was
planned for a while you know this is
hopper just finished chemo and it's a
it's bittersweet because the clock is
tickin but we wanted him to have one
last hurrah up on the lake because he
loved it there and you know get the
family together as well because it had
been a while since we'd done that but
right before we went on break it was
just this whirlwind of chaos and and
listen we're so grateful and all of you
have supported I mean you watching right
now incredibly if you're watching this
it's me in a car talking so I would
assume there's some level of buy-in by
the way I don't know how to these people
do all these videos that you see one in
the car while they're driving it do they
have they have mounts that they're doing
that they just have to do vlogs and the
cars I have no idea I've put a little uh
I put a little sandbag behind this to
hold it up anyway I'm very grateful for
the support but the point is before we
went on break it was really
stressful and so you have that it's kind
of like stirring this pot and then just
boom dumping it out you're going from
from 100 miles an hour to zero and it
was it was it was a tough process I
think a lot of people can probably
relate to this whoo-hoo
I guess work in jobs that kind of either
come in seasons or or sprints it's it's
hard sometimes to come down a little bit
and you know I got to say a lot of
people you see all these self-help gurus
talking about living in the present live
in the present live in the moment you
know what there is some truth to that
and that has been something that I've
been doing here and really trying to do
making no plans not stretching myself
and I think it's important for everyone
to do at some point just to be but it
also dawned on me that I don't think you
would ever be able to truly appreciate
living in the present to to truly I
guess the true to truly understand it be
grateful for what it is unless you had
lived your life not like an [ __ ]
living in the present every day in other
words unless you had lived your life
where you had been responsible and
accountable and taking care of other
people
working being disciplined then being in
the present doesn't mean anything right
unless you had done all of that it would
just be another day and I think you know
I probably need to do it a little more
than I do I think there are some people
out there we're probably the same way
but it is amazing to when people just
they they talk about live in the moment
be in the moment without talking about
the other side of that coin
what if Edison had lived in the moment
Tesla and for those who don't know I'm
not talking about the car I'm talking
about the act the man after whom the car
was named George Washington no great
person no great accomplishment has ever
occurred from perpetually being in the
present now in order to be able to plan
in order to be able to strategize in
order to be able in order to be
productive you do need to have moments
of breaks where you kind of shut this
off right where you can relax where you
can have some time to step back and
think and get perspective that's that's
why retreats exists that's why almost
every great leader or even just most
successful business people or pick
athletes they have a place to get away
and shut off these are people who tend
to be hyper hyperactive hyper focused
and then I guess that's kind of you know
with myself I have two gears I have to
have turbo and off but that's what my
wife always says there really aren't the
in-betweens
it's kind of a broken clutch and gears 2
through 4 trying to think
how many gears are there is it usually
five in a manual car you know this is
this is also odd see this is a video of
me trying to live in the present just go
with every thought have I can you know
I've ridden motorcycles for years I've
never driven a manual car but I did
actually there's an outtake reel and to
save a life the film and if you watch it
it's just me not engaging the clutch
properly installing and that's because I
had to drive it for the film and I had
never been in a manual car at that point
no one taught me uh and no one has
taught me since so I can ride a
motorcycle but I can't I don't know
maybe I wouldn't be able to use a manual
car anyway something else that I was
gonna say is is the reason that life is
all about rhythms and margins and you've
heard me talk about this before I had
one guy tell me one time hey your career
is not a marathon it's a sprint life
isn't America life isn't a sprint sorry
it's a marathon and it's not it's not a
sprint it's not a marathon it's interval
it's like interval training its sprint
sprint boom boom boom boom boom boom go
go go go go go hard and then keep moving
but you bring it down a little bit
because no one can be at a hundred
percent intensity for that long this is
one thing I always laugh at when I see
these kind of new fitness enthusiasts a
lot of like the CrossFit crowd and stuff
like that and they say well you know
then I'm gonna do a 30 second sprint
well you weren't
that wasn't a three that's not a thirty
second sprint whatever you're doing I
don't know what it is but it's not a
sprint for 30 seconds Usain Bolt slows
down after eight the human body is only
capable of going at maximal capacity
running sprinting for I think it's I
think it's eight seconds it might be
nine you can exhaust yourself and go as
hard as you can go for example for 30
seconds but it's not a sprint and this
is something this is why this is
important I'm gonna bring this around to
something relevant the house of a funny
story about Nick Jonas right after this
let's say you're saying you're telling
yourself you're sprinting for 30 seconds
okay and what I would like everyone to
do this everyone who does high-intensity
training of any kind measure your
mileage measure your output in those 30
seconds okay
go as hard as you can go you'll find it
drops dramatically after nine eight or
nine seconds you can't you can't sustain
it for 30 seconds so what happens is
you've already reached that threshold
you've already hit burnout and you're
just declining in energy if you go as
hard as you can go for 30 seconds or for
a minute you're gonna have that boom out
the gate burst of energy the actual
sprint and you're just going to decline
in performance and guess what it's never
gonna come back you're not gonna get a
second wind it doesn't happen that's
just that's just biology these are there
are certain limits this is one thing to
when people talk about living life
without limits but there are limitations
there are limitations oh man I never get
tired no you do get tired people get
tired oh man I can I can I can sprint
for it for 4:15 no you can't man I can
go for days without sleep no you can't
you can't do those things so
understanding limitations is important
understand that yeah be living in the
present is great when you can do it but
only if you balance that out with some
other rhythms and margins that are
intense and where you're you're living
and fulfilling your purpose and I'll
tell you this on this break living in
the present I hate to use that Hades
it's just just relaxing just unwinding
I've come up with with more ideas more
sketches more more meat segments than I
have in a long time I've been more
productive creatively because a lot of
times your best ideas don't come to you
when you're under the gun under a time
clock too so you do need that time
sometimes to plan it in being productive
okay all right let me tell you the other
story by the way August 1st is when I'm
coming back really looking forward to it
and I really enjoy the time out here on
the lake and with the family and hopper
and my in-laws it's been fantastic but
I'm looking for we have such a great
team at line with credit
I'm really looking forward to getting
back in and working with them and doing
some interesting stuff here heading into
election season so my dad and I are
driving or we coming back from oh we're
coming back from the the archery shop or
getting my compound though pressed and
kind of fitted in and we're driving back
and there's this taco truck outside of a
party store and it looks pretty good it
looks authentic so my dad and I pull in
order a few tacos kind of sit what we
typically do as we sample all the
different tacos to see what we like and
then order more and we go back sit down
a fan comes up and he says hey Steven
you know I really like your stuff and it
was you know it's always still very
humbling to this day if ever I'm awed or
uncomfortable if you come up and meet me
just know that I'm intensely
uncomfortable with Fame and likely to
say something wildly inappropriate so
comes up says hey really a pretty kind
of kid can I get a picture sure great
thank you for watching and I go to sit
down then there's this other guy next to
me
who is uh who is Mexican turns out his
mom owns a truck and he looks at me and
I've had this happen before he goes and
I know you from somewhere of me and this
sometimes happens when someone
recognizes you in public
other people may not know who you are
may not follow but they just know that
someone else thinks you're famous and so
it almost creates this it creates it's
odd sort of mass hypnotism or then they
want pictures even though they don't
know who you are does it happen before
and there's no good way if someone says
hey I know you from somewhere you know
maybe if I were if I were a narcissist
will I host a no spin zone you know I I
just I always say I I've got one of
those faces behind me from somewhere I
said I just yeah I don't know I got one
of those faces but yeah so eat the tacos
delicious fantastic tacos we leave go
home the tacos were so good my mom and
dad go back to that now my dad drags my
mom you have to go to this taco truck
it's like 20 minutes out of the way I
don't know you have to go so he takes
her he goes back and he says hey to the
lady who owns the truck it was so good I
had to bring my wife we're coming back
for dinner two meals in one
a and she goes she was oh this way you
were here earlier and you missed him we
had a celebrity come by and by the way
this is not racist this is how they
sound my dad goes Oh a celebrity she was
yeah it was about the time you were here
too Nick Jonas was here now if I had
done that the other way for example if I
said that George Lopez was there that
would be incredibly racist but I guess
white guy sideburns I don't know I don't
look at do you think I look anything
like Nick Jonas but to me so funny was
the guy thought he knew me from
somewhere but when and convinced his
poor mother that I was Nick Jonas and
it's Seth and she was looking through
receipts all that to try and find the
Nick Jonas receipt and I wouldn't be
surprised if there's a picture of him on
the wall at the taco truck so the point
is this August first we're back live in
the present but only if you haven't
lived an [ __ ] life your whole life
and you've actually attempted to
accomplish something and held yourself
accountable then you've earned yourself
the gift of living in the present you
can treat and that's what it is the
president is a gift huh I'm sure someone
else has done that and never get too big
for your britches because even when you
have you have a few fans come up and
recognize you and support you there's
still a Mexican guy at a taco truck who
will confuse you for Nick Jonas
he who exalts himself will be humbled
I don't even exalt myself by the way I'm
like I am an entire I am an entire
second Jonas Brother heavier than Nick
Jonas